[Music]  you auditioned for Jumanji the role went  to Kirsten Dunst that is true as a kid  did you go to see Jumanji after I saw  Jumanji but I liked it I liked too much  yes but you sit down go [ __ ]  why didn't I tell you I wasn't bitter  enough at then The Parent Trap Lindsay  Lohan was the girl in the Parent Trap  right did you audition for that yes you  did  did you go see The Parent Trap with  Lindsay Lohan no I do not you know I  started to get bitter at that point did  you really it was hard for you yeah you  auditioned for lame is right I  auditioned for lame is yeah didn't get  it cuz you had laryngitis I did I had  laryngitis but I tried but I don't know  if that's why I didn't get it I probably  didn't get it because I thought I wasn't  right for it Anne Hathaway got it and  she was great in that film she's back  she got an enema that was your academy  or